DEMOCRATS NEWEST STARS IS A
FOCUS OF TONIGHT ANGLE.
IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS, THE
MEDIA HAVE ANOINTED LIBERALS
LIKE ANDREW GILLUM, GEORGIA
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE STACY
ABRAMS AND TEXAS SENATORIAL
CANDIDATE RITA O'ROURKE AS
DEMOCRATIC SUPERSTARS TO WATCH.
>> IS A STAR IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> GILLAM BRINGS SOMETHING.
>> SOME OF THESE CANDIDATES,
LIKE BETO AND GILLAM, YOU GET
THE STAR POWER.
>> Laura: IN THESE FINAL WEEKS
OF CAMPAIGNING WE ARE LEARNING
MORE ABOUT ALL THREE CANDIDATES
THAT SHOULD GIVE ALL THE VOTERS
IN THEIR RESPECTIVE STATES
REASON TO QUESTION THE NONSTOP
HEIGHT.
LET'S START WITH ANDREW GILLUM.
TEXT MESSAGES REVEAL THAT THE
TALLAHASSEE MAYOR EXCEPTED A
HOTEL ROOM, TOURS AND TICKETS TO
THE BROADWAY SHOW HAMILTON FOR
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPERS.
WITHOUT EVER DISCLOSING THE
GIFTS.
ONLY THOSE DEVELOPERS WERE
UNDERCOVER FBI AGENTS AND THE
DEVELOPERS HAD BEEN IN TOUCH
WITH ME OR GILLAM ABOUT A
REAL ESTATE PROJECT IN
TALLAHASSEE.
HIS OPPONENT RON DeSANTIS
REPUBLICAN, CONFRONTED HIM WITH
ALL THIS AT THEIR DEBATE ON
SUNDAY.
>> THE QUESTION IS, DID YOU PAY
FOR THE HAMILTON TICKET OR DID
THE UNDERCOVER FBI AGENT PAY?
>> I'M A HARDWORKING PERSON, AND
I KNOW THAT MAY NOT FIT YOUR
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT PEOPLE LIKE
ME DO BUT I WORK HARD FOR
EVERYTHING I'VE GOTTEN IN MY
LIFE AND I DON'T NEED ANYONE
HANDING ANYTHING TO ME FOR FREE.
>> Laura: IT GILLAM GOT A
DIFFERENT ANSWER WITH CHUCK TODD
YESTERDAY.
>> WITH FLORIDA VOTERS AFTER 15
YEARS, I SERVED HONORABLY,
RESPECTIVELY, AND HAVE SERVED MY
COMMUNITY WITHOUT SO MUCH AS A
STAIN ON MY RECORD OR ON THE
NAME.
>> Laura: HE SPINNING AS
BADLY.
AND TEXT MESSAGES JUST RELEASED
BY GILLAM'S LOBBYIST FRIEND,
HE'S TOLD CLEARLY ON AUGUST 10TH
OF THE 16TH THAT MIKE MILLER AND
CREW HAVE TICKETS TO HAMILTON AT
8:00 P.M.
AWESOME NEWS, GILLAM TEXTED IN
RESPONSE.
NOW WHETHER HIS BROTHER GAVE HIM
A TICKET OR NOT, HE KNEW THE
SOURCE OF THE TICKET.
WE SUPPOSE A DEVELOPER WHO
NEEDED HIS HELP.
THIS IS WHY THE STATE OF FLORIDA
ETHICS COMMISSION INVESTIGATED
GALEN.
THE PROBE REMAINS OPEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS FLORIDA STAR SEEMS TO
BE FALLING.
TONIGHT AT HIS SECOND AND LAST
DEBATE AGAINST DISANTO'S, GILLAM
WAS PRESSED ON THE ISSUE AND
THINGS GOT HOT.
>> HE WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE HE'S
NOT UNDER INVESTIGATION.
>> I TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR NOT
HAVING ASKED MORE QUESTIONS.
I'M RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR AND IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA WE GOT A
LOT OF ISSUES.
>> NICE TRY, BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE BEEN IN THE ROOM WHERE IT
HAPPENS.
I SUGGEST THAT GILLAM MOVES TO
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE HIS VIEWS
AND HIS STYLE OF POLITICS WOULD
FIT PERFECTLY.
NOW LET'S MOVE ONTO THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
IN GEORGIA WHERE THIS VIDEO
FOOTAGE OF GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE STACY ABRAMS SURFACE.
NOW IT SHOWS HER AND OTHERS ON
THE STEPS OF THE GEORGIA CAPITAL
EARNING THE STATE FLAG IN
PROTEST.
THAT WAS 1992.
ABRAM SOUGHT TO EXPLAIN HER FLAG
TORCHING THIS WAY.
>> 26 YEARS AGO AS A COLLEGE
FRESHMAN, I ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER GEORGIANS INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA WERE DEEPLY
DISTURBED BY THE        RACIAL D
DISTURBED BY THE        RACIAL V
DISTURBED BY THE        RACIAL S
DISTURBED BY THE        RACIAL N
THAT WERE IN THAT STATE FLAG
WITH THE CONFEDERATE SYMBOL.
>> Laura: LET ME BE TRUE BUT
THE GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA AT THE
TIME DID NOT SET THE FLAG ON
FIRE ON THE CAPITOL STEPS.
HE WORKED WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO AMEND THE FLAG, CHANGE IT AND
REMOVE THE CONFEDERATE SYMBOL
THAT PEOPLE FOUND OFFENSIVE.
SO DOES A CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR
CONSIDER IT RIGHT TO SIMPLY
DESTROY PUBLIC IMAGES OR SYMBOLS
THAT SOME INDIVIDUALS FIND
OFFENSIVE?
THAT'S A QUESTION THAT THE
PEOPLE OF GEORGIA HAVE TO
ANSWER.
AND THEN, THERE IS SUPER BETO.
YES, SOME STREET ARTIST IS
TRYING TO DEPICT O'ROURKE, WHOSE
REAL NAME IS ROBERT FRANCIS, AS
SOME KIND OF SUPER HERO BUT HIS
ACTIONS BELIE THE DESIGNATION.
BACK IN 1998 WHEN THE TEXAS
SENATORIAL CANDIDATE WAS 26, HE
WAS DRINKING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
DRIVING AND HE STRUCK ANOTHER
CAR AND ATTEMPTED TO FLEE THE
ACCIDENT.
SINCE THEN, HE TRIED TO SOFT
PEDDLED THE DRIVING DRUNK, WHICH
I DID IT COME AS A TERRIBLE
MISTAKE FOR WHICH THERE IS NO
JUSTIFICATION OR EXCUSE.
>> Laura: YOU SHOULD ALSO NOT
TRY TO EXCUSE YOURSELF FROM
ATTEMPTING TO LEAVE THE SCENE OF
AN ACCIDENT, WHEN IT WAS CLEARLY
YOUR INTENTION.
NOW WHEN ARRESTING HIM IN, "THE
DRIVER ATTEMPTED TO LEAVE THE
ACCIDENT, BUT WAS STOPPED BY THE
WITNESS."
NICE TRY, SUPERMAN.
AND I HAVEN'T EVEN MENTIONED HIS
1995 BURGLARY CHARGES FOR
BREAKING INTO THE UNIVERSITY OF
TEXAS AT EL PASO, OR THIS
HEINOUS COMMERCIAL.
MUSICAL PHYSICAL >> Laura:
MORE LIKE LEADER OF THE HACK.
AS VOTERS HAD TO THE POLLS, IT
WOULD SERVE THEM WELL TO SEE
THROUGH THE LIBERAL MEDIA PIXIE
DUST ABOUT ALL OF THE SO-CALLED
DEMOCRATIC SUPERSTARS.
WHO THESE PEOPLE REALLY ARE,
CHECK IT OUT.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IN.
OPEN BORDERS, HIGHER TAXES,
GOVERNMENT RUN HEALTH CARE,
GUN-CONTROL, AND MORE
REGULATIONS ON BUSINESS.
ALSO REMEMBER, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
STARS, WHO ARE ACTUALLY SEEING
THE LIGHT REFLECTED FROM A STAR